today Washington State and Snohomish
Health District officials announced the
first u.s. case of a 2019 novel
coronavirus the patient is currently in
isolation if scientists always warn us
about some new weird death virus and
we're like what's the plan they're like
ah wha sure I have the second confirmed
case of corona virus in the US right
here in the Windy City a government
plane is planning to evacuate Americans
from Wuhan the only way China can be
walking down cities any harder would be
if the coronavirus were protesting for
Hong Kong's independence the White House
announcing that it has created a
coronavirus task force President Trump
is set to ban foreign nationals who pose
a transmission risk from entering the
country looks like by April you know in
theory when it gets a little warmer
miraculously goes away hope that's true
the number of infections on the diamond
Princess cruise ship has doubled the 15
within a couple of days is going to be
down to close to zero health officials
in Washington State come from a patient
has died from the infection here's what
we know about New York City patient when
the US does not have enough coronavirus
test kits it's a virus like the flu
Kovach 19 can be characterized as a
pandemic we will be suspending all
travel from Europe customers have been
snapping up everything inside the family
of the victim 26 year-old Brianna Taylor
shot an officer-involved shooting on
Friday morning as speaking out my
administration is recommending that all
Americans avoid gathering in groups of
more than 10 people direct all
individuals to shelter at their place of
residence long lines and hours of delays
as travelers returning from Europe had
to undergo screenings for the
coronavirus
stocks going down gold is going down
credits going down everybody's in
complete liquidation mode do you think
using the term Chinese fires that puts
Asian Americans
I think they probably would agree with
it people right here in the valley say
they are getting backlash just for being
asian-americans a drug called
chloroquine hydroxychloroquine and it's
shown very very encouraging early an
Arizona man has died after he took
chloroquine phosphate because he
believed it would protect him from the
corona virus and numbers from Italy
tonight only worsening Spain's suffering
over 460 deaths in the past 24 hours
Brazil's own president Jair bolson ro
describes the threat as a quote little
flu be nice is DJ in club quarantine on
Instagram live the single biggest
economic relief package in American
history CDC is advising cloth face
covering it's volunteer you don't have
to do it I don't think I'm gonna be
doing it millions more Americans have
filed unemployment claims from the
chronic burden of medical ills is likely
to make people of color especially less
resilient to the ravages of koban 19 a
phased and deliberate approach to
reopening Shake Shack turning a 10
million dollar government loan meant to
help small businesses Georgia's governor
reopening his entire state on Monday
Arkansas Colorado Montana and
Mississippi will also begin lifting
restrictions tensions mounting in
Michigan hours after protesters stormed
the State Capitol demanding an end to
the stay at home order in Huntington
Beach
hundreds of protesters swarming the
coast no one has been arrested or
charged armories family says all he was
doing was jogging the United Kingdom has
now recorded Europe's highest number of
deaths several thousand workers have
gotten sick on the Mississippi coast
today casinos reopening folks coast to
coast are risking kovat exposure seeking
Sun and
fun this Memorial Day weekend a
bystander's cell phone video captured
the incident a Minneapolis officer
pinning George Floyd face down pressing
into his neck officers then shot up in
riot gear more than 100,000 American
lives lost to the corona virus another
huge leap in coronavirus deaths in
Brazil while everyone is facing the
battle against coronavirus black people
in America are still facing the battle
against racism and coronavirus we will
be today terminating our relationship
with the World Health Organization that
appears to drive directly into a barrier
where a large number of protesters were
gathered police in riot gear fired gas
canisters and used grenades containing
rubber pellets to scatter largely
peaceful demonstrators or a photo-op the
biggest gathering London has seen in
weeks
the officer called on a protesters mask
and pepper sprayed him k-pop fans are
overwhelming social media hijack a
hashtag used by white supremacists today
would have been Brianna Taylor's 27th
birthday in Arizona Kovac case is
spiking by 34 percent over the past week
my worst nightmare a disaster in Georgia
you can see people lined up some waited
for hours to cast ballots protesters
chanting black trans lives matter
outside the Brooklyn Museum US Food and
Drug Administration withdrew emergency
approval for hospitals to use
hydroxychloroquine to treat kovat 19
fours in Texas once again shut down now
a second time as we have seen a spike in
certain areas they had just been
reopened only three weeks the u.s. is
the Green Line which plateaued and is
now rising sharply that is what failure
looks like and that's where we are
[Music]